the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
in this video i will explain why hbo is
all of a sudden releasing so many game
of thrones related videos on their
social media accounts
now maybe some of you haven't even
noticed but the official game of thrones
youtube channel has re-released all of
their trailers for the series
i know i found this to be interesting
because it had been well over a year
since they released anything on their
channels this has left many fans
wondering why they did this
hbo's official youtube channel has
released some game of thrones related
videos as well
i know when i woke up the other day and
noticed all of these videos i was
definitely wondering what was happening
it actually made me very excited again
because it reminded me of the days when
hbo would release some new footage from
game of thrones
then i would have to race home so i
could make a video about it as soon as i
could
now although i have seen some of these
videos before i did watch a few of them
again
this is when i also noticed there was a
lot of speculation
surrounding the sudden release of all
these game of thrones videos
some fans are wondering if they did this
so they can generate some new excitement
for the release of their upcoming series
house of the dragon
other fans are also wondering if they
did this because they are secretly
making a new season of game of thrones
or something else involving the main
story
well the answer is rather simple hbo
will be celebrating a decade of game of
thrones with its month-long event the
iron anniversary
there's nothing in the world more
powerful than a good story
not armies
not gold nothing can stop him
no enemy can defeat it
you're in the great game now in the
great game is terrifying
it has already been a decade since hbo
first released game of thrones back in
april of 2011.
hbo will be offering fans a new way to
experience this series
while they're still developing their new
upcoming series house of the dragon
there has been some speculation that
filming will begin on the new series
this month
i have made some videos on that already
now this iron anniversary this month
will include a range of features and
events for game of thrones viewers
from personalized hbo max episode
curations
a game of thrones mirror throne and more
throughout the month of april
starting monday hbo max users will see a
game of thrones spotlight page which
will bring them to episode curations for
casual fans
or those new to the series or spoiler
laden curations
featuring easter eggs for die hard fans
it will also include more than 150
behind the scenes videos and extras
cast interviews clips and trailers later
this month on april 10th
hbo will begin the game of thrones
marathon with all episodes from the very
beginning
airing on hbo2 starting at 10 am
eastern standard time the marathon will
challenge fans to binge the entire
series on hbo max to help raise money
for global charities including women for
women international
world central kitchen unicef and the
trevor project
for two weeks during the marathon game
of thrones cast members will rally on
fans as they binge watch the series for
a good cause
now to make the marathon a little easier
super fans
and influencers will receive a custom
kit of essentials
the marathon will also feature six
different routes to offer direction to
viewers
who want to experience the series in a
new way from episode collections focus
solely on daenerys targaryen's journey
to those spotlighting the series
action-packed battles
so if you are still wondering why hbo
has suddenly released all of these game
of thrones
videos now you know i know i will
definitely check out some of this myself
i am interested in seeing some of the
extras like the behind the scenes
footage
as well as the interviews with the
actors from the show
now i know there are a lot of fans who
say they will never watch game of
thrones again
but i'm not one of them in fact i've
already watched the entire series since
it ended
i still have my own issues with how it
was ended that's no secret but i don't
let it stop me from enjoying every
aspect of the story
there are still a lot of things that i
love about the show now
if you're a little disappointed they're
not making a new season of game of
thrones
then i would recommend checking out some
of the recent videos i have released on
this channel
i have been making my own version of
game of thrones season 9
in hopes of answering some of the show's
biggest mysteries
now it won't be as good as the real
thing of course because it's not live
action
or anywhere near as good storytelling
like george rr martin's
but maybe you will find it interesting
or entertaining in some way
who knows if you give it a chance maybe
you will like it
as of right now i have released three
episodes with many more on the way
as always if any new information is
released regarding game of thrones
or any of their other shows and
development i will fill you in on the
details as soon as i can
until then i will get back to making my
next episode
i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
you